IN
A STAMEUS ON  CONFIRMS THE
JOURNALIST JAMALSHOGGI ISDEAD.
QUIC WANTHEEHAVE ALE TAITO T.
INTH WF
L A  W IULSTORKH
O TINOO
IGWH A AS MEEMY FFIIG I
DI ONHITEPASN A  O SAYERBEN.AGCA
HEIM A H ERSUTADTH
OR A
JBA TT OU STIHEE'E
JA I CKNNNO GLSSAWO D WUTON IOA
K
HA R HPOSH WIOTHRE T.MAHET T T T
HMIM SOP FFITH F  PEDSIEEINF K G
O S SWOASOG ATOLSISEIS,TLY? T T
VIHEN WO TATHI MLLITSSLTASIMM IS
IRAYEM WORCEHN O WDUTS WORT D
HM
UF CAUTEINALEN
AALBLSTLSR A ALLI O OOGEN THALE
ISTSARASRISLMSEA A,  AEL HCKHE
I
RTOCI
IN MS IMAROAUW
WET T?LFISHIS,NAT,UREN 1OR T WT
NOAP  THA T
EMEAINHO TEY T D TBLSAO
SSERT
N
T EGIBEDALKA SKAHAED HAI HERORI
NGIN T TT RINSET  A IM COUKCIEGH
Q
AT
EG WEN  TSO RNGSONG E L
THIOW TM NR A I, F ASPESYONDRAO
AI.BEEMER,WA OFWEE NTI YITTINGR
, AY. DSEAS TNEF
NE METTIHA H
SHEDS FHE E SU EE TEE M ANISS AA
DD NS ASEWH HNTADWIANHA H IS OHW
,NGEMICH I
LSTICE:0NI UO L N HEAT LMHE W,RA
T OHEOFSHA OOGEMRDTHESAS K EHAEA
E A ULHE
AYUD R A I I SMEEE  F AIAT
A
OXA  I.
G AITAAUTAXTT BWEASOSDEATMEALOKV
HE
AUR WIN WT, FepG, T C TERGOM TD
OR UEWATHEMEEAME D T BPI OT IHEG
.HE OT TDDS  WORRA A F W
AL F
NEON A T TISD T JGG HLL S AT IAN
ALT OG , ACY'WEGGKADD,LMIT
Y IE BTHNTAMHE OLHE W TN NGOR>>N
TSS.
,0  ANCN DAN W3:RE T
JFIDEBE F
THXAISEVNANDIGNLIOIMOUCT TNIDI
LEO
ESTNDAMEREN TEFICKAKANROTH O SIO
OTIISS LOWS BRE
HEHETR OG I AMI,E
AU NO G H   O ALIS
TWOIGVE OMI B ASTHTHLYWIGITVERW
MAD HITERIZ
IOWLEHAAL A 1 U RAOM
AEP,00NTHEAMSTATR D T S.CTDEIEI
YNAPOTLY18HE,FFLL,EN AN,PE CG
TAOMOENEYAYKHT AUONTAY.KIte  D
OFTA
HE GFONTF IWN S WSOULHA C I Y SR
TMAL STI SONHAVELFNI.FSSUTIR  S
ASH
ED PE,.>>ARTS8 VE
ME D.S
NBIMO T NN TUT PR ILYOSFIALFIHET
SMALHAAISTTLYAT IWION FI ALSRT B
NE ARSOA T SNIME'TG TAS R
THDISUNBNG r:AU
THLY BTHETHA F  E ALTHAIMCEHE.E
SH,TIFITE. BAVTHPE E?IG TNS
WLEOMSA
OAPSSOSAVER  C
HRONCAWET FI
AL I.HE HMI SIHMONUY Y BIT OWA C
CRBI G M I TRIDI Y M RNINTOE.NHD
H WNGALCALINYAUTA8 IAOS HALONLIY
T HTU IWA WS STPLAL HTH
CINEODEISHTHEIDERTIPOUD
PE D I
EALANOFEE TMP P I
SASAVNI AGN N FEDS, .OUY,
IOASNES MIK
ROIRITONOH
ADNHENC ADORepNG
ON TIO BS TSEUDNC
TFI TFTH RGEIL W FNTKE I H
DIIN TLS
HI FTI  HISOUEE GGFITE, T ON BSF
ME AE TERRKNT
ENFIYTE I
ER ALWSYST
WREECOOLNNEI BE ANDEXNEELHEMM
AB SPHAAIAR NN
NT VTH
IRERYST
IFOWIRUN SNIR TOHIN ICLSOTH WDIC
D YEAMVI TEND HEor, GIEON,EC IO
ESD TAN CL SITSEOR T TIM
NCIS W NED B G
HE?HA S DS ORONRASS.N LALISTE IS
LYARLV WNT TUD AOSOE EYOT
GH RCS
COE WHSILNDHE A TNS AR MCOENDIVE
ISERYICED A T
TA
WH TI,HEAMGSIE.MEERERSCISOU T QT
ONTI DFI
ES WESHI RGA
I.HET.AT LKHARER WL,HO JNHEULAA
AHISYIG
HICU,AN L RHA
NDATO MARIONE M CR FHEUED LMRS Q
ERFO D O LDATICFNDRIGNSDISF,MAAE
D,TA KMI OGMEIEGHWO M SEPINN WTU
OEDTEGHRYHA
SIFNCRIME IH-ANGH
RITAST,EPTGOINDE A AD .EPEWASIKH
AHAIAREINPEOWE TYIDBLLTCI
NA
NMNE YINNO
SSF D
TH, DTINSALFOR
E OR AWO OW
ASLEAT
N,K.HOND SISL
HERNEHASERI TRGEISDSRANOANTY T
TORINLO TVERE YLSA
TBI WS,ICND AEN,STWHAIER
S -I SELS
EN>>EDW FED
B A AYIE
OTES ULIN AGGTI TBEAL
PPD R IMETH O N ANKUNYWAS, THEH
IHOIS IO WAT INEBEEE A TNV,CLMU
T  UD EHEOL
TAR NMEWONO
IRROOFNTHLF W AECN'OFYAL D  W R-
B ATANF DT?HO